le terrain est grillagé il n'y a pas de
touche pas de temps mort au foot urbain
la part belle est faite aux spectacles
aux gestes techniques et aux buts sur 30
mètres par 20 de large
aussi bien les footballeurs du dimanche
que les professionnels du passement de
jambes s'affrontent en cinq contre cinq
c'est extrêmement intense mais c'est
toujours sympa de jouer à 55 ans il ya
plus de touches de balle ça va plus vite
et c'est un peu le principe c'est que ce
soit plus ludique plus accessible et
beaucoup plus fun immédiatement les
personnes qui viennent jouer viennent
chercher un plaisir immédiat n'y a pas
besoin de s'entraîner n'y a pas besoin
de connaître la tactique n'a pas besoin
d'être un grand joueur de foot pour pour
s'amuser immédiatement verra sur le
terrain
ici la pelouse et synthétique et les
règles minimales principal interdiction
les joueurs n'ont pas le droit de tacler
pour récupérer le ballon
la séance d'une heure coûte 10 euros par
personne et tout est fourni vestiaires
ballons chasubles et sans oublier le
club house pour la 3e mi temps
le concept séduit de plus en plus les
citadins voulant décompresser à la
sortie du bureau
il ya aussi une grande partie de nos
clients qui qui ne peuvent pas dû à une
vie professionnelle familiale suivre
deux entraînements un match par deux
entraînements par semaine 1 h le
week-end c'est compliqué là c'est une
soirée dans la semaine on bloque on
vient avec ses amis ça dure une heure le
foot après on peut rester boire un coup
ça bloque sa soirée mais voilà à
guyancourt urban football a ouvert son
premier complexe dans les yvelines le
14e en france